-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
You made it.
You're watching at home.
Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's get to some news, here.
Well, guys,
today President Biden
hosted a summit
at the White House
with the leaders of Mexico
and Canada.
Yep, basically,
Mexico and Canada heard
all of America blasting Adele
and wanted to check in on us.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys --"
That's right,
when Trump was president,
the regular meeting between the
three leaders never happened.
Now that it's back, it'd be wild
if the Mexican president
was like,
"Oh, and here's a check
for that wall."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the leaders spent
time talking about immigration.
Biden complained
about the number of Mexicans
coming to America.
Trudeau complained
about the number of Americans
coming to Canada.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Biden's very busy.
Tomorrow, he is going to pardon
two Thanksgiving turkeys
at the White House.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
That's what we're doing.
We're pardoning turkeys, here.
And they just revealed
their names.
Their names are
Peanut Butter and Jelly.
[ Laughter ]
Come on! After this year,
how are they not named
Pfizer and Moderna,
you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Peanut Butter and Jelly?
Yeah, Peanut Butter and Jelly.
Thanks to supply chain issues,
that's also
what we'll be eating
on Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
today CVS announced
that it will close 900 stores
over the next three years.
[ Audience ohs ]
Right now, JCPenney is like,
"Wait, how did we make it
through the pandemic
and you guys didn't?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Kidding me?"
Sounds like a lot of closings,
but all 900
of those CVS stores were
on the same block.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
I saw that T.J.Maxx
is raising prices on some
of its higher-end brands.
Yeah, I guess they're trying
to give the whole store
a more upscale vibe.
Check out this latest ad I saw.
[ Classical music plays ]
-[ French accent ] Introducing
the new T.J.Maxx.
Home of elegance...
[ Laughter ]
...style...
...and sophistication.
-Isn't that interesting?
Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
They're changing their image.
Hey, I saw that Oreo's
coming out with a new cookie,
called Oreo Thins Extra Stuf.
[ Laughter ]
What?!
So, basically,
they're just Oreos, right?
Can I see it again? Can I see
the picture of it again?
At this point,
just cut out the middleman
and start selling
an IV bag of stuf,
[ Laughter and applause ]
you know, at this point, right?
We'll do that.
Hey, this is fun --
in a recent interview,
Dwayne Johnson said
that he wants to be
the next James Bond.
[ Audience oohs ]
You'll know
that he's been cast
when they announce the next
Bond villain as carbs.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, instead of a martini,
he'll ask the bartender
to shake a dozen raw eggs.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- today, an original
copy of the U.S. Constitution
was expected to fetch
up to $20 million at auction.
Wait, they're auctioning off
the Constitution?
[ Laughter ]
Man, the U.S. really is
running out of money.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know you could do that.
We're living
through crazy times,
when a Bored Ape NFT
is worth more
than the U.S. Constitution.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
I heard about a man in China
who was banned
from an all-you-can-eat buffet
for eating too much.
[ Laughter ]
In China, he's kicked out,
but in America,
they'd hang his picture and give
him a show on the Food Network.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We have a great show, everyone!
Give it up for The Roots!
-♪ Mesmerizing ♪
♪ State-of-the-art caffeine ♪
♪ Over your head
like "Omniverse" screen ♪
♪ Not the average savage
that curse queens ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm
from his worst dreams ♪
♪ First we handling
first things ♪
♪ Subsurface unseen ♪
♪ Grab the whole planet
by the purse strings ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What a show we have
for you tonight!
He's the star of
"Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings,"
which is streaming now
on Disney+,
and he's hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend,
with musical guest Saweetie.
Simu Liu is here tonight!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Love that guy.
Plus, she stars in the new film
"Passing,"
available now on Netflix.
Ruth Negga is here!
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And we got great music.
-Come on.
-One of our pals.
He's been here forever.
Since, I think, probably,
we were doing late night,
I guess, right?
We got music
from Big Sean and Hit-Boy!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Big Sean!
I got -- I'm in one
of those weird...
-Belts?
-Yeah. I'm between holes
right now and --
-Hey! Family show.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-No, no.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-You have your belt loop --
-It's either super loose --
-When I lost weight,
I go with that.
I remember that one.
-Yeah.
-It's a good memory.
[ Laughter ]
-Those were the days.
Yeah, I was in that hole
and then...
[ Laughter ]
...but, now, I'm at this other,
normal, one.
-Right.
But it's a little loose.
-It's too loose.
-But, if you go
to the next one --
-It's decoration now.
-Yeah.
-You got to the next one,
it's too tight.
-Might as well put
a giant watch.
Might as well get
the WWE Championship belt.
-It's a fake belt.
It's not holding my pants up.
-Why don't you get
some like rope?
Like Jethro it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and just like a draw?
-Cinch it, yeah,
just drawstring it.
That way, you're never off.
-I mean, my pants aren't going
to fall down.
-Mine did.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Remember?
Remember when
my pants fell down?
-Hey!
-It's a family show.
-My lawyer told me not
to bring that up, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I remember your pants.
-It was the wrong hole,
that's why.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're --
I don't know.
It just feels --
I feel silly.
-You know what you can do?
-Take it off?
-Take it off, man.
Who cares?
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-It's not easy.
-Is your mic?
Is your mic on your belt?
-Oh, my microphone, yeah.
Like wow, did I just --
I just became
the weakest man on Earth.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It's like, "Aah!"
-My mic pack is on the belt.
Alright, let me try it again,
alright?
-Yeah. You know what I would do?
Just take it off.
-What?
-Yeah, take it off.
Take it all off.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
Wha-pssh!
♪♪
-Pssh!
-Wha-pssh!
Wha-pssh!
♪♪
-Have you ever used a whip?
-Me? Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I have.
-Did we do a sketch or something
where we were whipping things?
Like plates or something,
we were breaking targets?
-Something like snapping a thing
up at "SNL"?
-Oh, maybe it was
"The Whip Master"
[ Laughter ]
with Bill Murray?
-Yeah.
-That was fun.
That was funny.
Yeah. I never got to -- Anyways.
Here's what I would do.
-What's that?
In the future, maybe --
this is a bad idea --
but maybe, if you have like
a metal hit,
just put magnets in your pants.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
Some of those stick
to titanium, yeah,
and then, you don't have
to worry about anything.
-Yeah, then you can play
the groove.
-Right?
Well, they're not falling down.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Nothing falls down.
-Or get a bolt.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Put on like a rivet
and then, just a bolt sticking
out of you,
then, you can just take
a washer and a bolt.
Now, your pants are never
going to fall down.
-Bolt your pants on?
-Yeah, bolt your pants on.
[ Laughter ]
And you could be real fast,
call it the Usain Bolt.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Did you hear
about the Toyota recall?
-Oh, yeah. That's bad.
-Did you guys hear about it?
It's not good.
Here, take a look at this.
-One of the most popular cars
in America
is getting a recall.
Toyota recalling
recently made Camry models
after a problem was discovered
with the braking system.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
Man, I just bought a Camry.
-Jeez, I'm sorry
about that, Tariq.
-It's fine.
Don't worry about me.
I still have
my heavy-duty RAM truck.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh," what, Jimmy?
-Roll the clip.
-More than 240,000
heavy-duty RAM trucks
[ Laughter ]
are being recalled in the U.S.
-What?!
Well, how am I supposed
to go anywhere
for Thanksgiving next week?
-I don't know.
Sorry about that, Tariq.
-I don't have a turkey at home!
Let me see.
What's even in my freezer?
Oh! I did just buy these
really good chicken patties
from Trader Joe's.
[ Cheering ]
-That sounds nice.
-Yeah, yeah, I got the
chili lime chicken burgers
and some spinach feta
chicken sliders.
-You might want to check
your freezer
[ Laughter ]
for Trader Joe's
chicken patties.
The company recalling...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-I'm sure you'll figure
something out.
-What else do I even have
in my kitchen?!
I guess I do have various brands
of Wild Cold Smoked
Keta Salmon Lox.
The Oregon Lox Company
is recalling various flavors
of its Wild Cold Smoked
Keta Salmon Lox.
-What am I going to eat,
ground beef?!
Oh, let me guess --
it might be contaminated
[ Singsong ]
with plastic!
[ Laughter ]
-Nearly 7,000 pounds
of ground beef
might be contaminated
[ Singsong ]
with plastic.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-I give up!
I'll just eat my dog's treats.
[ Laughter ]
-Where are they from?
-Sam's Club, of course.
-Sam's Club is pulling treats
from its shelves
[ Laughter ]
because they
could contain metal.
-I'm. done!
-Come on, now,
there has to be something
that you're excited about.
-I mean, I did just make
that big investment.
-Oh, yeah.
In what, again?
-I bought 900 CVS stores.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, we'll be right back.
I want to talk to you
during the commercial break.